[Musik]
ja der krieg tobt weiter die russische
offensive im osten des landes geht
weiter voran und es gibt leider leider
sehr schlechte nachrichten heute morgen
vom ukrainischen generalstab wir sehen
uns die lager im osten des landes hier
haben wir in den regionen aktiv im
norden lugansk ihr im osten und dem
süden und aus empirischer ganz im süden
die russische mega offensive die seit
etwa zwei wochen andauert um eben vom
osten her die ganze ukraine zu erobern
oder zumindest im osten der ukraine zu
erobern und wir haben heute morgen grad
vor demokratischen generalstab gehört
dass abermals vier kleinere dörfer
allerdings wichtige dörfer die eben um
die gekämpft wurden die gehalten wurden
hier in der region easy um im süden von
partie verloren gegangen sind an die
russische armee und wir haben gestern
ganz klar da kann es mal einschreiten
ganz klar von von der russischen seite
gehört dass man eben hier weiter
vorstoßen möchte dass man unbedingt
weiter vorstoßen möchte um den die
verbindung zwischen sloweniens auf der
einen seite und den epro dieser großen
ukrainischen metropole auf der anderen
seite hier zupacken kann das noch mal
versuchen einzuzeichnen hier gibt es
also aktuell noch eine eine autobahn wie
irland geht diese autobahn ist eine
lebenslinie für die ukrainer die dort
eben kämpfen die dort weiter an die
front halten sollten die russen bei
weiteren easy um vorstoßen ihm fehlen
noch etwa 20 kilometer dann wäre das
tatsächlich ein großer schritt auf ihrem
weg dahin sozusagen die ukrainische
armee etwa 30 bis 50 tausend soldaten
dort einzukesseln wir wollen uns mal
angucken wie die russische propaganda
das ganze beschreibt sie zeigt nämlich
panzer sie zeigt dass unser panzer
vorstoß das ist unsere armee die hier
weiter vorrückt südlich von easy um
sollen diese bilder entstanden sein und
wir sehen tatsächlich ein panzer nach
dem anderen dazwischen immer mal wieder
schützenpanzer aber eben vor allem diese
dieses bild einer vorrücken ende einer
sich bewegenden russischen armee die
ebenso zu sagen weiter vorstößt und die
in ganz klar sagt unser ziel ist
autobahn xy stadt ist sondern wir werden
dorthin gehen wir brauchen noch etwa
zwei tage und dann werden wir die
ukraine abschneiden das also offizielle
bilder der russischen propaganda die
auch in den sozialen medien flyer
verteilt werden wir wollen uns aber mal
ansehen wie diese offensive in realität
aussieht also je seit dieser propaganda
und dazu habe ich zwei sachen
vorbereitet zum einen weil diese drohen
aufnahme diese drohnen aufnahmen man
kann es kaum glauben auch die teil der
propaganda und zwar von der sogenannten
volksrepublik lugansk von ihrem militär
sozusagen
man schämt sich offenbar nicht diese
bilder zu verbreiten man ist sozusagen
auch stolz darauf diese bilder zeigen
die stadt nur wo tosca not over tokyo
schiefke eine kleine stadt mit über 2300
einwohnern und wir sehen in den drohnen
aufnahmen die völlige zerstörung jeder
mensch wurde hier vertrieben oder
getötet und ich habe versucht das mal zu
vergleichen wir sehen also erstmal den
drohen flug hierüber und wir merken uns
einfach mal diese drei dächer hier das
ist nämlich von google eine aufnahme und
wir halten das mal kurz an und sehen uns
an das war das erste dach das war das
zweite dach und das war das dritte dach
das sind drei wohnhäuser hier
nebeneinander von dutzenden wohnhäusern
die völlig zerstört wurden die ihm von
der russischen armee vernichtet wurden
aber man hat offenbar gar kein
schlechtes gewissen das zu zeigen und
das als erfolg zu verkaufen wir sehen
uns das noch mal die ganze stadt an auch
hier ist die drohnen hoch geflogen und
wir sehen die gesamte stadt also etwa
aus 45 gestiegen häusern bestehen zum
größten teil völlig vernichtet ich habe
hier einmal das zentrum eingeschaltet
das verwaltungszentrum was man so ein
bisschen sieht wie sozusagen die die
vernichtung vonstatten gegangen ist
nochmal der vorher nachher vergleich
damit wir das einmal wirklich genau
sehen
dass wieder von google earth und ich
habe mal drei dinge eingeschaltet einmal
hier links eine shopping center einmal
hier eine schule hier ein wohnhaus mit
einem roten dach und hier nochmal diese
dieses verwaltungszentrum und wir sehen
uns das ganze mal an wie es jetzt
aussieht noch mal mit den gleichen
häusern drin so und wir halten das
einfach mal fest das shopping center
also hier auf der linken seite
vielleicht kann man sich ein bisschen
genauer angucken dort verschiedene läden
das ist dieses haus was hier sozusagen
gestanden hat völlig zerstört hier noch
ganz gut zu erkennen das rote dach eines
der wenigen häuser mit dem roten dach
man sieht sie also hier nochmal das foto
davon auch völlig zerstört die schule
der stadt die war hier angebracht völlig
zerstört und als letztes das
verwaltungszentrum das hat man schon
vorher gesehen auch in schutt und asche
gelegt kein einziger mensch ist in
dieser stadt mehr da die russische armee
hat dieser erobert stolz wie sie darauf
ist befreit von den nazis wie sie sagt
und in wirklichkeit hat sie dem erdboden
gleich gemacht und alle menschen
vertrieben aber nicht nur die ukraine
leidet wir sehen uns nochmal letzte
bilder aus sapporo japan aus einer
region die wir gezeigt haben und zwar
hier im süden wo ebenfalls russland
versucht eben diesen kessel zu schließen
also auf die stadt sah borussia
vorzudringen und daneben den großen
bogen zu schlagen hier richtung kreativ
auch dort dringt die russische armee
langsam voran aber wir sehen auch mal
wie die russische armee hier leidet denn
das sind ukrainische drohen aufnahmen
kann ich denn noch machen die natürlich
keine zerstörten russischen städte
zeigen sondern ausschließlich zerstört
dass russisches militär wir sehen hier
123 schützenpanzer da vorne einen
brennenden panzer der russischen armee
alles ist völlig völlig zerstört und
völlig völlig tot wir sehen gleich noch
eine weitere perspektive von weiteren
zerstörten schützenpanzern russland
leidet aufgrund von putins entscheidung
werden wir jeden tag dutzende vielleicht
hunderte russische soldaten getötet
trotzdem geht putins offensive weiter
sie ist brutal sie vertreibt ukrainer
sie tötet eigene soldaten südlich
natürlich auch ukrainische soldaten und
putin hat trotz allem widerstand und
trotz diesen kampf wird es der ukrainer
nicht aufgegeben und versucht weiterhin
den osten der ukraine mit seiner mega
offensive unter kontrolle zu bringen
[Musik]